iPhones Millennials and the sacrament of
self-love have infected every aspect of
society from Alex Jones's browser
history all the way up to the White
House and even the Vatican we will
discuss the virtues and vices of
selfishness then on this day in history
George Washington shows the difference
between pride and dignity
finally the mailbag on Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we got to get right into it today
there's so much to get to beginning with
Alex Jones's browser history the the
question here is selfishness because
this is something that cuts across
conservatives and leftists I remember
when I was 17 years old I was introduced
to ein Rand the author of The
Fountainhead and what's that other one
book that nobody's read Atlas Shrugged
and the virtue of selfishness and this
is the her philosophy her ideology is a
selfish ideology it's also atheistic and
I like every other seventeen-year-old
who reads eine rand immediately bought
it this is a phase that I think every
seventeen-year-old boy has to go through
is really liking Iran for a couple years
and then usually people move on past
that some people still like really love
her forever and ever and she talks about
the virtue of selfishness when is
selfishness good when is selfishness bad
when it is selfishness when can it be
used to a better purpose and when does
it make us look ridiculous and degrade
our humanity let's begin at the back end
of all of that here is Alex Jones
explaining why in a in a videotape of
his cellphone browser he had what
appeared to be transgender pornography
coming up mr. Jones take it away and
also what about the trans porn on your
phone Alex are you order to talk about
that say that again transport on your
phone that's all they keep talking about
you know I saw a couple of news articles
about that it's ridiculous I was like
looking up some reporter we're trying to
hire today and punched in some number
and it popped up porn on my phone
everybody's had porn pop up on their
phones hundreds of times so I'm sitting
with a phone on air showing it to
everybody because I couldn't get a URL
up in the studio and then like something
pops up like oh my god and I looked at
it wasn't the news blurted out because
there was nothing there they blurred it
to then say something was there then you
went to it was some porn menu I probably
had porn menus pop up 500 times on my
phone so I appreciate your call I mean
it's the same ladies and gentlemen
there's two types of people people that
look at porn and people that lie about
it but I wasn't looking at porn on my
phone I don't take phones on air that I
look at porn on
and so I saw all that I didn't respond
to it I mean if I respond to half the
attacks on me
it'll be ridiculous but I'll say this
the Amazon ads the viagra ads the weird
non plastic bag ads are taking my iphone
over I thought didn't used to be that
bad like Android jeans note to self
never show cell phone screen on the air
ever never see Alex Jones I actually
don't really want to beat up on Alex
Jones for this because I felt the same
way when Kurt I can Wald that
insufferable left-wing writer when he
got caught looking at tentacle porn on
the internet there's this sub-genre of
pornography where its tentacles and he
got caught looking at it and he gave
some bogus excuse for he said oh uh it
was just a joke haha right everybody it
was just you know and which is he was
obviously looking at tentacle porn and I
sort of feel this way with Alex Jones
because he's exactly right there are two
kinds of people people who have looked
at pornography on the internet and Liars
at least among men at least among guys
there are like statistically in the
United States one-hundred percent of men
have looked at naked ladies on the
internet or in the case of Alex Jones
they have looked at men who look like
naked ladies on the internet because
perhaps mr. Jones was drinking the same
water that the frogs have been drinking
for the last few years I said I wasn't
gonna make any jokes about it and I did
that's awful
you know because everyone's done it
everybody has looked at porn on the
internet especially for the generation
of people like my age and younger who
grew up basically with the Internet like
a full 100% of people have have seen
porn on the internet so that isn't the
issue
it isn't about judging people for
looking at porn on the internet it's not
about judging Alex Jones it's not about
judging kurd I can hold or whatever but
it does this is very important because
it shows porn usage for what it is like
there's a reason that he's embarrassed
by this there's a reason I just made
that note you know don't ever show your
don't ever show your phone on camera
there's a reason people are ashamed of
this which is that it's a shameful thing
it's a shameful thing to look at
tentacle porn or whatever what here's
the proof of this
the Norm Macdonald theory on sex he has
a whole bit on one of his albums about
have sex as a dirty shameful filthy
thing that it's obviously only meant for
procreation and his evidence for this is
that when you go into your room to have
sex you close the blinds
you don't like open the windows but a
camera there broadcast it to all your
friends and and obviously that's even
more so true of when you look at porn on
the internet when people look at porn on
the internet and then they get caught
like Alex Jones even Alex Jones who is a
master of just exposing himself
literally exposing himself he takes his
shirt off a lot he's just out there he's
not ashamed of anything even he gets
flustered even he says oh well I didn't
and these are crazy and I don't know he
even he can't spin this you're and even
Kurt I can Walt says Zoe this wasn't
true this didn't happen people get very
flustered because it's obviously a
shameful thing and the reason it's
proliferated is because it's so easy
everybody has seen it you get it
instantly nobody can catch you it's very
difficult to catch you so people say oh
it's a harmless activity but it isn't
really harmless you know a lot of
studies have been done on this a overuse
of porn and high speed internet porn and
video porn can cause erectile
dysfunction in young guys
it can cause really perverted fantasies
it's caused guys to stop wanting to
sleep with their wives or girlfriends
because it doesn't match the fantasy
important you know we talked a little
bit about this I think yesterday that
porn is a fantasy and so it's a shameful
thing but this should be a lesson to
ever obviously people when when the
lights are out and the walls are closed
and the windows down people do things
that they're not proud of that's human
nature that's that is just built into us
but this is a lesson that we shouldn't
do that you know these things do come to
light and you don't you just don't want
to to do those things you know what is
the old I think when old Jim coach of
mine said a character is what you do
when you think nobody's watching so you
know if you're looking at transgender
tentacle porn on the internet when
nobody's watching that's that's not a
good thing because it's it's selfish
it's ultimately selfish to just sit in a
room and pleasure yourself it's not
gratifying because you're not doing
anything you're not helping anybody
you're not producing anything and and
you won't it won't
make you happy over time just like any
other selfish activity doing drugs
abusing alcohol you know staring in the
mirror and admiring yourself or whatever
I mean that's like the extreme example
of selfishness
anytime you're just doing something for
your own pleasure your own gratification
you're gonna get tired of that and
ultimately you're not going to be
fulfilled there are some uses though
there are some uses to selfish behavior
if you can put your self-interest and
channel it toward a public good then
selfishness is not a dirty thing then
it's not like the tentacle porn and
Kanye West describing Donald Trump -
very self-interested men actually
explains this very well and that's why
selfishness is not necessarily a dirty
word and Paulo politics kanya take it
away I feel that he cares about the way
black people feel about him and he would
like for black people to like him like
they did when he was cooler than the rap
songs and all this stuff yeah and he and
he will do the things that are necessary
to make that happen
because he's got an ego like all the
rest of us and he doesn't he wants to be
the greatest president and he knows that
he can't be the greatest president
without the acceptance of black
community okay is something that he's
gonna work towards but we're gonna have
to speak to him yeah
I need to go with you to the White House
and I got a couple things I got to say
so this is a longer interview and you
know he goes on and on about this but
the point is very important which is
Donald Trump doesn't want to offend the
black vote he doesn't want to offend
black people he wants them to like him
he remembers in the 1990s you know there
were all these rap songs about how cool
it was to be Donald Trump his Donald
Trump was this billionaire playboy and
that's you know that's very popular now
he wants to get that back he wants to
channel his self-interest for black
people it's not it's not that kanye west
says Donald Trump he's thought through
the ideals of the American Founding and
he realizes that all men are created
equal and endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights because that
comes from the natural law in the
natural creator and therefore we only
had blood no it isn't that he gives him
he gives a much straighter argument that
I think everyone can believe which is
that he wants black people to like him
because he wants to be liked as he wants
to be a successful president that's
that's a good enough answer I think
people on the right conservatives mocked
us sometimes they say oh he's he's so
narrow he's so shallow Trump he's so oh
who wants Kanye West support Kanye West
is shallow and selfish and not he's not
this high ideal guy fine but they're
doing good things you can channel these
natural instincts you can channel lower
passions toward a public good I mean
there's there is a selfishness there
that's a good thing if Donald Trump can
be a good president for everybody help
everybody succeed put black unemployment
at historic lows put the economy at
historic eyes high market highs you know
have wages increase if he does that
because he read the Federalist Papers
one day and it really opened his eyes or
if he does that because he just wants
the history books to be nice to him
either way I'm happy either way the
black unemployment rate goes down either
way the stock market goes up either way
I win that's fine you know we don't need
to treat the presidency like it's a
religion we don't need to treat it like
it's the Vatican we nowadays we might
have to treat the Vatican like it's the
presidency but we'll get to that later
ooh we don't have to treat it in these
exclusively idealistic terms if he's
using his selfishness to
become a good president that's a very
good thing and this applies not just to
the individual players in politics this
applies to national policy to the
Washington Post has this story today
this is an absurd story but it shows you
it shows you where that the logic of
this ends up especially for the left and
it shows you why you do need
self-interest or you can't look after
anybody else from the Washington Post
this is the headline quote u.s. is
denying passports to Americans along the
border throwing their citizenship into
question so it's based on this policy
right now the US isn't if people present
their documents they say here's my birth
certificate or whatever I want a US
passport but if they were born along the
southern border the State Department is
saying hold on a second we need to prove
that you're a citizen now people are up
in arms they're saying this is racist
this is denying Americans their rights
this is bigoted that some dumb-dumb on
Twitter was comparing Trump to Hitler
because of this widget by the way you
remember Donald Trump deported that Nazi
a couple weeks ago that should buy him
some he's not Hitler credit for a little
while but that's neither here nor there
here is what the piece goes on to say in
the Washington Post quote on paper he's
a devoted US citizen his official
American birth certificate shows he was
delivered by a midwife in Brownsville at
the southern tip of Texas he spent his
life wearing American uniforms three
years as a private in the army then as a
cadet in the border patrol and now as a
state prison guard but when 140 applied
to renew his US passport this year the
government's response floored him in a
letter the State Department said it
didn't believe he was an American
citizen okay so that's bad that doesn't
sound good on its surface right there's
a guy serve his country
40 years old and they said they don't
believe he's an American citizen so this
has to raise a few questions why don't
they believe he's an American citizen is
it is this question just or is it unjust
and has this happened before is this
some totally new thing so despite the
headline despite the first scare
paragraph the the article actually goes
on to explain all of this and it should
refute the entire headline because this
goes back to the first sentence of the
article four sentences his official
and birth certificate shows he was
delivered by a midwife in Brownsville
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah the official
one the question is is that true so the
piece goes on quote the government
alleges that from 1950s through the
1990s some midwives and physicians along
the texas-mexico border provided us
birth certificates to babies who were
actually born in Mexico in a series of
federal court cases in the 1990s several
birth attendants admitted to providing
fraudulent documents so just listen even
to even when they're admitting that this
is a totally legit thing the washington
post can't quite give it to them they
say the government alleges blah blah
blah but then it meant later in that
same paragraph they say in a series of
federal court cases the birth attendants
admitted to providing fraudulent
documents so it's not that the
government alleges this it's that we
know for a fact it's true because the
people who did it admitted it years ago
so that forget alleges this we know this
is a legitimate thing this isn't the
government trying to pull a fast one we
know this is a legitimate thing and is
this new is this something that just
happened is this a brand new policy it's
never happened before
Trump's just using it as an excuse to
deport people he doesn't like or to
discriminate against people he doesn't
like is that's what's being alleged by
the left but the same exact piece in The
Washington Post goes on but based on
those suspicions the State Department
during the George W Bush and Barack
Obama administration's denied passports
to people who were delivered by midwives
in Texas Rio Grande Valley
did you really bury the lede doesn't it
the last thing says not only during the
last Republican administration george w
bush but even during the previous
democrat administration under barack
obama this exact same policy was in
place nothing new so why is this a news
story it's a news story because the
mainstream media are trying to use it as
a cudgel against donald trump's they're
going to dig up something that was
barely reported on if it all reported on
when it happened in the first place
they're gonna say see Trump's Trump's
being a racist trinks being this trumps
being of that the reason I bring this up
those not just to beat up on the
mainstream media which is a daily hobby
it's a wonderful thing to do I encourage
it but the reason I bring it up is
because of the policy itself which is we
have not just credible evidence we have
proof that
some of these birth certificates were
fraudulent the during the 1950s to the
1990s we're talking about a four decade
period here five decade period and so
the United States has two options here
either it can say oh well it doesn't
really matter if we're giving foreign
nationals the rights of US citizens
that's okay that's fine whatever hey
it's okay what what does it matter to us
those guys are poor in Mexico and they
whatever they can do that or they can
pursue their selfish interest they're
there at their self-interest in this
case for the United States is to protect
its borders to protect the its
sovereignty to protect the legitimacy of
its citizenship and to kick people out
who shouldn't be here
now this seems icky to people all the
whole left is saying that selfish that's
selfish that's selfish some to be
selfish governments have to pursue their
own interests and when governments don't
pursue their own interests when they
don't pursue the interests of their
people it's not just that they're being
charitable or compassionate or something
they're being tyrannical they're being
tyrannical if a government is not
pursuing your interests if you are not
being represented by your government
that that isn't a small matter that's a
that's a matter of the government
becoming tyrannical of opposing the will
of the people which in in the United
States is not kosher that's not what our
republic was built on it's a very very
bad thing governments have to pursue
their interest these days among the left
and among the idealistic ideological
right they're pretending that countries
don't have interests this is where
nationalism has become a bad word we're
gonna talk to your impose oniy on the
author of the virtues of nationalism
we're gonna be talking to him I think
next week about this this issue today
the country has its own interests as a
bad thing all you heard from the
idealistic right all you heard from the
left is Oh Trump he's he's saying that
other countries need to pay up to their
responsibilities he is saying that the
United States is gonna pursue our own
interests he's saying we're gonna put
America first
where are my pearls where can I got a
clutch where are they they what's wrong
about saying America they said that
America first is a harkens back to
Charles Lindbergh or something it
doesn't harken
back to Charles Lindbergh in the minds
of the people using it today the
Americans who say yeah I think we should
put America first they're not thinking
of Charles Lindbergh they're saying we
have a national interest and it's
incumbent upon the government to follow
our interests because we're the people
were their bosses there's nothing wrong
with that that's self-interest it isn't
you know people draw a difference
between self-interest and selfishness
you know between being childlike and
childish one one of those is bad one of
those is perfectly appropriate and it is
perfectly appropriate for the government
to pursue the interest of the people
putting America first is not a bad thing
then let the late Senator John McCain
ran his 2008 presidential campaign on
the phrase country first do you remember
this was the whole country first thing
and other candidates have used this true
they say country first can someone
explain to me the difference between
country first and America first America
is the country right we're talking it
we're not talking
these people aren't running for
president of Mexico or president of
Hungary or something right it's America
first or country first and yet it's but
it's a bad word you're not allowed to
say it's a good thing for countries to
pursue their interest because in the
United States by the way when the United
States pursues its own interest
everything gets better for everybody
when the United States is allowed to
pursue its own foreign interests abroad
the world is more peaceful when the
United States is allowed to pursue its
own economic interests the world is more
prosperous when the United States is
allowed to pursue its own environmental
interests the environment improves this
was the issue of this pair of climate
treaty we pull out of the Paris climate
treaty because we say we're putting our
country first you don't get to take away
our sovereignty you don't get to tell us
what to do what happens we're the only
people who improve the economy or
improve the environment so many other
signatories of the Paris treaty actually
are destroying the environment they were
not living up to their promises they're
polluting at even higher rates the
United States when we pursue our
interest things get better this is
almost always the case we've got to move
on a little bit but I as a matter of
national policy don't let the mainstream
media fool you don't let them pretend
that a country pursuing its own
self-interest is a bad thing
self-interest can be a very good thing
this is the premise of liberal economies
this is the premise of liberal democracy
is that when you allow people to pursue
their interests in good faith to pursue
their interests in good faith and
discipline themselves into order
themselves and not just look at
transsexual porn all day but to actually
discipline themselves and pursue virtue
but when they pursue their interests in
that with that discipline things get
better freedom works and it does you
know when when Americans keep an orderly
sense of self interest and virtue and
pursue their interests the country
thrives the world thrives when they do
that without the sense of discipline
then it falls apart and then they start
worshipping fire demons in the Nevada
desert have sex with each other in or
Genomes you don't want that I mean these
things can fall apart but self-interest
can be a good thing freedom works when
you have people who are ordered to it
when when liberty doesn't become life
sensuousness and this this perversion of
the idea of liberty this perversion of
the idea of self-interest is nowhere
more apparent than in this billboard
this was going around Twitter yesterday
this billboard is unbelievable the
Billboard says do we have the words that
it's something to the effect of black
women look after their families and they
take care of themselves
abortion is self-care abortion is
self-care and I so I'm looking at this
thing and all these progressives are
sending it around Twitter they're saying
yeah support black women so yeah I just
the logic of this billboard is support
black women kill black babies because
it's not even saying like all women or
over there it's saying no no we need to
kill specifically black babies and
that's progress that's progressivism in
2018 is kill black babies at a higher
rate because it's self-care and the
argument here by the way is that somehow
it's good for a mother it's good for
herself to kill her child there's no
evidence of that mother Teresa said I
believe in 1994 that the greatest cause
of evil in the world the greatest policy
issue of evil in the world is abortion
everyone mocked her they said no what
about genocide what about this what
about that but she said if a mother can
kill her own child that is the greatest
font of evil interpersonal evil because
if a mother can kill her own child what
can't we
do what won't we do is there any bond
more sacred than that from mother to
child and if you can murder your own
child what won't you do and that's what
they're saying they're saying now it's
self care this is not proper or
self-interest this is real selfishness
this is base wicked selfishness and you
don't want to do that because when a man
is wrapped up in his own self he makes a
very small package indeed you know you
don't only if you if you're just there
staring at the transsexual frog porn or
whatever I don't know what it is if
you're just doing that you will not be
fulfilled do you ever you know whenever
someone satisfies the flesh that can be
you go and you just eat a table full of
food or you drink three bottles whiskey
or you do whatever you do on your cell
phone browser or whatever or you leave
the orgy dome at what's the what's the
festival called Burning Man you leave
the orgy dome at Burning Man I don't
think people ever walk out of there and
they say gosh I feel great about myself
now yeah I really did I really pleasured
myself I gave myself a lot of pleasure
you know what they're gonna read at my
funeral someday they're gonna say you
know he owed John John lived a lie he
went to the orgy dome and looked at
stuff on his cell phone brass or an
eight a table of food and guzzled
bottles of whiskey morning tonight
he really pleasured himself let it let
it be said of that great and glorious
man he pleasured himself nobody wants
that nobody wants that on their as their
epitaph nobody wants that on their on
their headstone but that's what this
stupid billboard is saying they're
saying it's really self it's really
caring for yourself to kill your baby
nobody not a soul not the biggest shout
your abortion proponent in the entire
world
once it written on her headstone here
lies Sally Jones she killed her babies
nobody wants that it's a shameful thing
it is far more shameful than looking at
transgender porn on your browser it's
far more shameful than that we all know
that that's true and the people who put
up these billboards and say it's self
care its self care it's shout your
abortion it's good it's loving it's they
know it's a lie
it's such an absurd lie kill black
babies that's progress we that is such
an absurd
and no amount of singing it doesn't
matter how big your billboard is gonna
get doesn't matter how loud you shout
your abortion that isn't going to change
the fact that is a shameful thing there
the next one they're gonna do is
euthanasia they're gonna do it for
assisted suicide but you know black
women take care of themselves they have
to look after themselves assisted
suicide is self-care that's what they're
going to say that's that's that is as
incoherent as a abortion being self care
it's as incoherent those things are in
self care when the challenge that we
have to do because we have a broken
human nature and we have original sin is
to take our inherent selfishness the
pride that caused the fall and turn that
away from ourselves to not look away to
channel all that to do something good
and that can be done that can be done in
politics as we're seeing it can be done
in the government we're seeing it can be
done in business if those things can be
done but that's the only way we're gonna
do it we're not going to do it do it by
denying the reality of selfishness and
we're not going to do it by by by
pretending that awful shameful things
are somehow good and glorious this of
course brings us to the Catholic Church
I do have to address this in our last
minutes before the mailbag here well I
do want to correct one thing I think I
said on the show the other day I
referred to that whistleblower that
high-ranking Catholic official the nun
CEO to Washington the Vatican's
ambassador to the US I referred to him
as a Cardinal Cardinal figa no he's not
a cardinal he's an archbishop but he's
not a cardinal and it seems like a minor
distinction it's easy to get confused
but the reason that's important is
because he's not a cardinal he's not in
a power play a personal power play in
the Vatican he's not you know in the
College of Cardinals or something like
that there's there's a lot less to
selfishly gain from this there's just
the this is much more clearly an act of
an act of conscience and an act of love
for the church to air at this dirty
laundry which so many a cleric so many
Vatican officials don't want to do but
I've got to play this for you
this this guy at Cardinal cubish I said
that's unshared Obol people refer to
this guy as Cardinal cupcake which is
not nice I wouldn't do it nice to do but
cubish I think
she pronounced soup ish but people call
him cupcake so then they think it's
cupich I believe it's super whatever his
name is this is a guy who he's the one
who came out immediately said the Pope
doesn't have to say anything well I'll
let him tell you himself here's Cardinal
supers the Pope has a bigger agenda he's
got to get on with other things of
talking about the environment and
protecting migrants and carrying on the
work of the church we're not going to go
down a rabbit hole on this the record
shows that whenever there's actionable
information
Pope Francis acts quite frankly they
also don't like him because he's a
Latino it's not just about the Catholic
Church let's look at all the agencies
and institutions that deal with children
on day to day basis anything else
anything else you want to blame this on
except for except for what's actually
being discussed this is unbelievable
look at what he said just there I can't
even go through all of that he's saying
that it's because people are racist that
they're attacking him they're saying
that Pope Francis can't address the
major sex abuse scandal that he is now
implicated in by a high-ranking
incredible church official because he's
got to talk about what air conditioners
and subverting immigration law is he's
got to talk about global warming and
immigration so he can't address the
serious accusations credibly leveled
against him then that what at what else
what does he say he says we have to talk
to about other groups because because he
makes a fair point here which is that
the Catholic Church does not have higher
rates of child abuse than any other
religious denomination according to any
study and children are orders of
magnitude more likely to be abused by
school teachers than by priests sure
that's fine but that's not where we're
talking about that's not what we're
talking about at all we're talking about
specifically this guy's buddy
Cardinal soup is buddy Cardinal
McCarrick who has been seriously accused
credibly so of abuse not just of
seminarians and priests but also of
minors we're talking about Pope Francis
who has been implicated in a cover-up
here but we're talking about another
story that just came out today which is
that Pope Francis apparently gave a
sweetheart apartment to really posh
Vatican apart
to a priest who was known to be a
problem priest to this guy what is his
name a Monsignor Luigi kaput see he was
known to be a problem priest he was
known to engage in sexual behavior known
to be a big issue he gave it to him as a
favor for his friend Cardinal Francesco
Coco Palmieri
Palmieri oh and this priest ended up
having a drug-fueled gay orgy in this
Vatican apartment for hours and hours on
end it's only because the neighbors who
also are priests almost certainly called
the cops on him he finally got arrested
for this there were serious sex abuse
and coverup issues here and what is
Cardinal su pitchers response no no no
we've got I've got more important things
to do than to deal with this this is the
classic response of the left by the way
which is that the left loves humanity
and they don't care that much about
humans they say no I've got I can't talk
about these people who have been
sexually abused I can't talk about these
people who have covered up sexual abuse
and who have been personally directly
implicated in this I've got to care for
humanity I've got to stop global warming
I've got to subvert u.s. immigration
laws III have a much more important task
than your silly little sex abuse scandal
give me a Brit this is outrageous an
outrageous response I mean this this
response by by the Cardinal is the most
tone-deaf response to a legitimate
social grievance since Marie
Antoinette's apocryphal line let them
eat cake which she didn't actually say
but this is this is at least just
tone-deaf as that and they need to give
an answer for it but I'm sure more is
gonna come out every day and by the way
well this is all happening just a note
for the New York Times the New York
Times ran a headline well all of this is
I mean worse and worse news every single
day for Pope Francis this is the
headline Francis takes high road as
conservatives pounced taking criticisms
public that's the news report that's not
an op-ed the news report from the New
York Times Francis
takes high road as conservatives pounce
taking criticisms public so they're
saying that they're judging that Francis
is taking the high road by refusing to
acknowledge the
legitimate and credible allegations
about him covering up sex abuse for one
there then saying that the news story is
not the credible allegations of sex
abuse but that conservatives are
pouncing and by pouncing they mean
asking questions about the credible
allegations of sex abuse and cover-ups
by the priests and then and then the
this is the best part the third part is
the New York Times headline is that the
Conservatives are pouncing and that's
bad and they're not taking I Road
because they're taking the criticisms
public so they should be covering them
up that's what the headline is saying
usually the Conservatives should be good
they should be nice and they should
cover up all of the sex abuse they
should cover up all of the cover-up of
the sex abuse this is uh this shows you
by the way for certain that the New York
Times does not care about the victims of
sexual assault
they do not care one little bit they
care about leftism and they have what
they think is a pope who is pushing
leftism and who was covering for
cardinals who are pushing leftism
and there does seem to be a strange
coincidence of leftism and these
Cardinals and bishops who are covering
things up and the that's all they care
that is what they clearly care about
here they don't care about abuse the
headline is begging them to keep
covering up the abuse now they actually
had to change this online because they
it was so beyond the pale it's the
online versions Vatican power-struggle
bursts into open as conservatives pounds
conservatives aren't pouncing there's a
credible allegation that these left-wing
clerics have been covering up or
participating in sexual abuse for a long
time that's what happened that's the
news story but conservatives pass they
do this in politics all the time you
know there's more I want to get to
there's another important story to get
to and there's this day in history man I
ain't get to anything today we got to
get to the mail bag though I'm sorry to
say we'll have to save those other
things for next week in the meantime go
to daily wire.com because we've got a
lot of mailbag what do you get you get
me you get the intro claims or you get a
bunch of Peoria's questions in the
mailbag that's coming right up you get
asked questions in the conversation I'm
practicing my ben shapiro voice I wanna
see how fast I can talk talk talk talk
talk but before any of that you got to
get the leftist tears tumblr you got to
get it because this hmm this leftist
here's tumblr tastes like the effects of
people pursuing their appropriate
rational self-interest this tastes like
the effects of enforcing immigration law
this tastes like the effects of Donald
Trump
doubling more than doubling his support
among the black vote which is
traditionally a Democrat stalworth vote
this tastes like the the virtues of
pursuing self-interest not the vices and
that's a wonderful thing because there
is nothing vicious about leftist ears
they are a true true wonder and a
blessing go to daily wire.com we'll be
right back with the mailbag
I never get to everything that I want to
get to but I also never get to finish
the mailbag and I'm probably not going
to today we're gonna give it a good try
though from Robert I wanted to point out
that smoking substances grown from the
earth to get high has been around for
thousands of years mainly in Asia so
it's not exactly a new drug i generally
appreciate your insight on most subjects
but your anti-pot rant was lacking depth
love your show well thank you for
watching the show I appreciate it I knew
I was gonna get this objection so I
wanted to head it off but I'll say it
again I don't deny that yeah smoking pot
has been around for like all of human
history using drugs smoking drugs to get
high too you know whether it be shamans
in the desert or eating or smoking
whatever in Asia or the pre Columbus
America's yeah that's been around for
all of human history that hasn't been
mainstream in the West that's true
that's that's from other cultures
absolutely in fact this is my defense of
alcohol alcohol has been with our
culture since the dawn of time Oh calls
been around a very long time in fact
Christ the from which we get our
Christian culture from whom we get our
Christian culture his first miracle was
to turn water into wine for drunk people
not just any wine but very good wine so
this was the argument people say if you
why don't we have pot pot is not as bad
for you as alcohol well I'm not arguing
that one way or the other I'm just
saying alcohol is part of our culture so
if you try to get rid of alcohol you're
going to fail you're gonna end up with
prohibition you're gonna it's just
simply not gonna work
you're butting up against thousands and
thousands and thousands of years of
tradition and culture and ideologue
think that they can get rid of thousands
and thousands of years of tradition
overnight but we know that that can't
really happen so I'm not I'm not arguing
one way or the other I'm just saying
that's not gonna work my question is why
would we introduce a new one why would
we introduce marijuana into the culture
marijuana doesn't come from our culture
marijuana was introduced as a mainstream
concept very very recently so why would
we help that become mainstreamed yes
that's part of asian culture whatever
shows but smoking things to get high is
part of a lot of cultures they can have
it that's their culture why would we
introduce it towards what's the benefit
why would we do it I see no reason I'm
not even
saying that like pot is a terrible thing
or that it's worse than alcohol it's
we're not saying that at all there's a
time and a place for everything that
places college know what 1 in 7
Americans smokes pot on occasion year to
year to year I'm not saying I'm just
saying why would we mainstream it why
would we legalize it why would we
encourage you if the government were to
pull away alcohol from our culture that
would be a real incursion that would be
a real interference into our culture in
our society but if the government were
to take it were to stop legalizing
marijuana that's not interfering in our
society marijuana has never had a place
in our society so why would we introduce
it now people have to think not
ideologically about this because
ideologue think they can get rid of
culture overnight they have to think
about this more broadly from a
traditional perspective from a
perspective culture in society and
conservative thought next question from
Emmanuelle God God with us hi Michael I
was wondering if you could speak to the
vocation of the artist particularly with
your background as an actor and now in
the context of Catholicism I've been
struggling with this for ages constantly
looking for something to tell me that
it's a good thing I wasn't built to be
an accountant or a mechanic or anything
with any conceivable life skill I have
no problem paying my dues working at a
regular job until I can do what I ought
that's not the issue I just want to know
that it's a good thing to aspire to that
the church and the world perhaps might
need someone like me thanks so much love
the show and keep up the good work well
as somebody who has no discernible hard
skills whatsoever I feel able to answer
your question of course you should
pursue art if that's what you should be
doing but you can't really you can't
plan these things out too much and if
you make an idol out of your art or your
preferred job or your preferred craft
you're gonna go down a bad path and that
isn't the thing that you should be doing
I'll say this as someone who's never
gonna work in this town again I still on
occasion get the opportunity to work as
an actor so I'm doing another kingdom
with Andrew Clavin right now we're doing
the second season of that the first
season was very successful second season
is going to be successful I've been able
to do a handful of movies and play as
some of which were good some of which
got good reviews and that's always nice
but you don't get to do it all the time
I say now the only time I get hired as
an actress by Ted Cruz a dennis prager
and andrew Clavin this is the last
employers
that doesn't keep me up at night I don't
I'm not crying and sad all the time
because I'm doing something different
than that you'll do what you can do you
take the step that's in front of you but
art is a wonderful thing I I've never
wanted to become an accountant or to
become mechanic or to do anything that
is practically useful whatsoever and I
think I'd be unhappy doing that and I
don't think I'd make a contribution to
that at all
but if you're if you're interested in
things such as art or politics
philosophy those sorts of things that
that's one to theology whatever then
pursue those things pursue what you
think that you're called to do a good
way to measure this to see if you're
actually doing the right thing is one
are you willing to work when people
offer you an opportunity are you willing
to do it even if it's not exactly what
you planned out you can never plan your
own life for you it never works out that
way if it did work out that way we'd be
in a very shallow poultry world so are
you willing to do that work do you do
you mind being led where the thing leads
you to go then perhaps you're you're
willing to do that and are you willing
to deal with it if you can't pursue that
art for a year or two years or three
years or you do something else if you're
willing to go where God is leading you
to go then you're on the right path if
you're making an idol out of your art
and your languishing and you're upset
all the time like like virtually
everyone is in Hollywood especially
actors and directors and writers if your
language and saying I want to do this I
want to do this I want to tell God how
my life is gonna go then you're not
doing the right thing and you should
really rethink your priorities from Jody
hey Michael
why was Alexandria Ocasio Cortes mmm why
was Alexandria Ocasio Cortes late to the
socialist political rally in Boston
because she was Stalin thanks Michael I
thought that was a question when I read
that I realized it had the punch line
built in I'm gonna use that that's
really got me use that while I wear my
shirt why were my she Guevara shirt from
Nathan hey Michael you have multiple
times put down churches that use
acoustic guitars I know there are
typically more problems with those kind
of churches but let's ignore that for
now I feel the same way but I don't know
why other than pure tradition it should
be this way because it's always been
this way
do you have a reason why some
instruments are more or less
propria to use from praising the Lord
and where why do you draw that line
I assume organs are okay but what about
pianos keep up the good work and God
bless yes there is a hierarchy certain
instruments are more fit for worship
than others and I say this as a guitar
player you know I've played guitar since
I was like 12 or something like that
actually enjoy playing guitar and
strumming around but guitar is a lesser
instrument the reason I've been playing
guitar since I was 12 I basically taught
me what it took a couple classes but I
basically taught myself how to play
guitar
most people teach themself how to play
guitar it's because it's an easy
instrument to play now certain composers
have have made good use of guitar
classical guitar made it a complicated
instrument but not not as complicated as
a violin for instance not as complicated
as the harp not as you know there are
there are higher instruments to play
harder instruments to play the French
horn whatever there are and they do
different things you know the ancient
Greeks and all wise people throughout
history have recognized that music plays
upon your soul it's the most important
of the arts because it speaks right to
your soul it can put you in a different
mood it can put you in a different
perspective it can make you rethink
certain things which is why when you
play really guttural visceral ugly
tribal music you feel less elevated you
feel less human than if you're listening
to Bach or something the what I think
should be used for worship is actually
just the voice I think the the early
church had it right I think the Eastern
Orthodox Church still has it right it
should be the voice I think the whole
liturgy should be sung the reason for
this is it takes out that personality
there's nothing worse than a you know
there I suppose there are some worse
things but when it comes to the liturgy
there's nothing worse than a priest
getting up there and and giving the
performance of Hamlet that he never got
to play you know he goes up there I'm
gonna really perform this gospel today
I'm gonna make you feel it with my
emotions and goes up there and does a
shtick and starts telling jokes and as a
little soft-shoe during his homily
people don't want that you don't want
personality you want the priest to be a
conduit between God and you you want you
want to see Christ through the priest
and this is why you want the ad orientem
facing you don't want the priest facing
you like he's doing a sticky vaudeville
show you want you and the priest
together to be looking up toward God to
be looking at the altar to be looking
through to heaven so I much prefer the
voice
Oregon is nice too there are a lot of
great old Protestant hymns that sound
very nice in Oregon and but you know
when you get to the guitar Church you
get these saccharine things Catholic and
Protestant alike you get these you know
eagle's wings and oh yeah it's really
like a bad 90s rock song that doesn't
that that will not lift you up to
worship that makes you just look back at
yourself and your own saccharine
sentimental pop culture and then looking
at the priest and seeing if the priest
is putting on a good show and if he's
entertaining you you know one of the
real giveaways for this is if people
applaud at the end of mass if you're
applauding then you're then you're going
to the theater I hope you I hope you
like the play and so is it a good
musical did they do that good dance at
the end that's a that's a better play if
you're if you're applauding people in
church you're probably not looking at
who you're supposed to be looking at so
I you know even when it comes to this
old Protestant Tim's the ones I'm the
organ and everything I really like those
very straight ones worth like oh we will
worship God and we're worshipping God
let's keep worship God you know whatever
those are great because they take out
this saccharine personality and they
they direct you toward God if if you can
do that with an instrument very good
certain instruments are more likely to
do that but otherwise use the human
voice I think it was a Gustin who said
to sing well is to pray twice to sing
well yeah that's an important qualifier
there but to sing well is to pray twice
and that's I think we should be singing
the whole time when we get up to heaven
we're gonna be singing and we should do
that in the liturgy because the mass
should be heaven on earth from Jonathan
we have more time I can do like one more
hello hello I've been single for several
years and have thought of getting back
into the dating game again but I have
little to no confidence is there some
way out of this trouble yes I'm gonna
give you the advice that Don Corleone I
gave to Johnny Fontaine when he was
trying to get out of his contract to get
a better contract imagine that these are
your shoulders you're gonna act like a
man what's the matter with you
you got act like a man that's that's the
answer you got to act like a man and
that should tell you every single thing
about it
you are a man you are a man gender is
not socially constructed biological sex
is not socially constructed act like a
man act like what you were built to be
you have no confidence just do it forget
about when when people say I have no
confidence that's because they're
thinking about themselves they go on
thinking of me should I be doing this
[ __ ] am I doing this right do I look
good and might wear this stop it stop
thinking about yourself don't do that
just act like a man acting like a man
doesn't mean dragging your knuckles and
like knocking the lady on the head with
a mallet or something acting like a man
means being a gentleman to doing the
other thing but what it really means is
focusing on the girl if you're on the
date focus on the girl if you're trying
to meet a girl don't be desperate
because when you're desperate you're
thinking about yourself you're just
think about your own desires your own
needs as a matter of practical where do
you meet girls there are a lot of places
you can meet girls you can meet girls at
a bar you meet girls at a church you can
meet girls in a club a lot of times you
can meet girls through friends you can
meet girls on those apps I kind of
missed the apps because I had a
girlfriend during the apps but I know
multiple people who have gotten married
from the apps close friends and family
of mine so the apps can work and you
know some of them are very religious so
you know some of the apps are to hook up
and and some or or not they're for more
serious things so why don't we use that
do whatever works
I'm not saying you've got to be prudish
about it and be waiting to meet her in
the choir loft at your church or
something you go meet a girl wherever
you're gonna go meet a girl but just be
confident about it you say I don't have
confidence just be confident but how do
I be confident just be act like a man
that's that's really what it takes when
you're when you're thinking of yourself
this is actually a perfect question to
end on because it ties exactly in with
selfishness and self-interest if so
they're used interchangeably today but
there really should be a distinction if
you're being selfish you're just trying
to use the girl to fill some hole in
yourself some desires I really want sex
or I really want dinner companion or
whatever but self-interest is it's not
good for man to be alone you got to go
out there you got to find a partner you
you want to men want women that's a
natural fact and you're gonna pursue
that self-interest and the way you're
gonna do it is do the things that men
are supposed to do hold the door open
pay for dinner
don't go dutch
dinner pay for dinner pay for the drinks
whatever and be interested in her this
is the advice for when you're on the
date
I am shocked at how men do not
understand this shut up and listen to
her
you'll it'll be the best conversation
it'll be they will love it this is
ironic because I talk every day you know
45 minutes to you but I'm telling maybe
it's because of that that I've like
learned this in every other aspect of my
life listen to them if you're just there
to pontificate then you're not you're
not going to learn anything you're not
gonna have a good time
it's only talking to people is only
interesting when they teach you
something when they show you some aspect
of human nature and I promise you at the
end if you let this girl talk for 90% of
the time then you're gonna walk away
she's gonna say well you're an excellent
conversationalist well I've never met a
better conversationalist but just do
that don't I know it's it's it seems
like a cop-out to say be normal be a man
go get the girl I know that seems like
I'm not giving you good advice I'm
giving you excellent advice but there is
no secret it's not in that book you know
the pick-up guidebook there's no trick
there's no you're gonna hack their brain
or what I know there's no you just
people can sense it don't be don't be
inauthentic be authentically the best
version of you be authentically who
you're supposed to be hope that helps
get back to me let me know if it works
out hey you've got a binge another
Kingdom because we're filming the new
season of another Kingdom so you got to
get through season one it the new season
is even better it's where the first
season was popular the new season is
even better it's been a lot of fun to do
it go to daily wire calm in the meantime
have a good weekend I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael no she'll see on
Monday
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Joshua ov era the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you